[Music]
all right we are live on the interwebs
I'm Dave Ruben this is the Ruben report
it is time for a Friday Round Table
Extravaganza and joining me today is a
New York Times best-selling author and
legendary that's right I'm coining him a
legendary journalist who I don't have to
put air quotes around Andy know and also
joining me for the first time is an
evolutionary biologist a fellow at the
Manhattan Institute and the founding
editor of reality's last F Colin Wright
Andy Colin welcome to the Ruben report
thanks Dave thank you I am glad to have
you guys and I thought I would start
with something although we're going to
discuss the woke week that was I'm going
to uh start with something that kind of
put you on the map Colin I've known you
for years and I didn't even realize
until 5 minutes before the show that
you've actually never been on the show
before which is very bizarre to me so I
I owe you one I'll try to make it up to
you uh but I want to throw up this meme
that you had created a couple years ago
that's going to look very familiar to
people we've shown it on this show a
couple times and what you created this
uh what around what year was that do you
remember I think I created it in 2021
2021 okay so now what you're seeing
there and the reason that this meme went
viral is because Elon Musk reposted it
and this was before he bought Twitter
but sort of as he was waking up
politically and seeing what was going on
uh in terms of free speech and
everything else uh he posted this about
two years ago and it went viral It Was
Your Meme and as people can see up top
in 2008 you're said the little character
that's me in the middle there is kind of
Center left then four years later 2012
you you can see the left the fellow
liberal has gone way way left and you
are now a little bit closer to the
center and then in 2021 now N9 years
later you can see me the me character is
now kind of on the right the left has
gone woke Progressive calling everybody
a bigot and the conservative is
basically like lol C I was kind of right
about a lot of this stuff I don't I
think that was the most uh time anyone
has ever spent explaining a meme in the
history of the world but Colin can you
talk a little bit about your personal
political Journey cuz it does very much
mirror mine it mirrors Elon I I can't
speak for Andy but I think it mirrors
his to a degree in a certain way none of
us are sort of people that you would
traditionally think would be more on the
conservative side of things yet here we
are yeah I mean it was partly inspired
by I think a video you did uh you know
years ago called you know I didn't leave
the left the left left me if that's
right um and so I was that was something
I felt very deeply given certain topics
like free speech and uh women's rights
and uh you know judging people by the
content of their character rather than
the color of their skin and all these
seems to have just been like completely
abandoned by the liberal left as I knew
it at the time and so I wanted to I just
felt this sort of like this ground shift
where like I had basically maintained my
own views my my my values um and then
the ground shifted underneath me where
those values used to be reflected in my
opinion on the center left best and now
I see them more refle probably on the
center right um so now I'm you know
considered to have been uh radicalized
by right-wing fundamentalists even
though uh in reality I've just basically
stayed in the same place and everyone
else has gone on the crazy identitarian
train uh the bullet train to the left so
uh that's that's sort of you know you
were definitely help uh sort of giving
me this vision of the left leaving me um
and I I was thankfully able to put it
into a meme form that seemed to resonate
with a lot of people so it's been it's
been a lot of fun yeah I mean that's the
beauty of memes they can get the ideas
out there to spread in a way that
talking about it sometimes doesn't quite
do Andy do you find some common cause in
that cuz it's kind of funny I actually
for we're friends outside of this show
and you've been on my show a million
times and I've read your books and all
that stuff I actually don't know all of
your political beliefs but I know every
time they write about you the mainstream
media they either call you a right-wing
conservative or all wrer you know one of
these crazy things which the way I know
you as a human has very little to with
what I can sense your political beliefs
are thank you Dave for providing a
little bit of that personal insight into
um your interactions with me uh I'm
based in the UK now um but I'm from
Portland Oregon that's where I did most
of my reporting that's how most people
have heard of me and now that I've spent
uh some time away from America and can
can look into US political culture um
while not physically being there um I
think a lot of the Ridiculousness and
contradictions are made much more
apparent and in one particular area is
how
radicalized um the left the liberal
mainstream left is in US it it it's it's
actually quite different in Europe yes
in in in UK and Europe they have the
woke um and the far left here as well
but they they really do it kind of they
exist on the fringes and are often
mocked by the some to left and some to
right I think in the US
um perhaps Americans don't realize
because we we've become really so used
to it is how radical the mainstream left
is if you look at for example I'm just
reading some older writings from uh ibam
X kendi um when he was known under a
different name and some of his older
writings were um
so just these racist Creeds against uh
white people re referencing their DNA
and their genetics and this person is
one unfortunately a many many upheld um
by the mainstream liberal Elite left as
a um as a figure we should take
inspiration from and look up to and uh
view as a moral guidance and also as an
intellectual so uh you know when when we
have these discussions about how
politics have shifted so radically let
say in the last just decade in the US
you know I I look at I look I look at it
with actually a lot of
Despair well let's get to the Hope part
because people know I like to do a
little Hope on this show and that's
actually why I wanted to have you both
on this week because there were a couple
wins against this woke craziness this
week the big win uh was that claudian
gay is now the former president of
Harvard she has resigned from her post
at Harvard after the anti-Semitism and
plagiarism Scandal we've got some info
here from Greg price who's another
journalist I don't have to put air
quotes around breaking here is Claudine
Gay's resignation letter to the Harvard
Community she writes it has been
distressing to have Doubt cast on my
commitments to confronting hate and to
upholding scholarly rigor to bedrock
values that are fundamental to who I am
and frightening to be subjected to
personal attacks and threats fueled by
racial animists now interestingly uh
Colin I referenced you earlier uh this
week on the show because you had a
prediction about how she would behave uh
once she would resign and you absolutely
nailed it so here's Colin Wright a
couple days ago prediction Harvard
president claudian gay will resign but
she will not admit any wrongdoing
instead she will claim to be the victim
of a racist right-wing Witch Hunt that
is impacting her mental health and
causing needless distraction for
students and faculty and then of course
here's one more from Greg price with her
doing just that uh breaking Claudine gay
just published an oped in New York Times
where she decries a attacks on education
and expertise says she fell into a
well-laid trap before Congress and says
that the people uh and says that the
people to called for her who called for
her firing trafficked in l and
stereotypes about Black Talent so yes
she did exactly what you predicted Colin
I suppose that that little man who tried
not to move too much in the meme is not
surprised by any of this no I mean it's
not difficult to predict when you
observed how these types of
identitarians work so remember the
objective of ideologies like CRT it's
not to ask whether racism occurred but
really how and to what extent a given
interaction was fueled by racism you
know they believe it's just baked into
every social interaction imaginable and
then we've seen the people like you know
the usual suspects ibam kendi
regurgitating those you know their
pathetic rehearse lines about how this
is white supremacy and we're all afraid
of black Excellence uh you know he
actually said that gay wouldn't have
been investigated or pressured to resign
if this was a white woman but you know
I'm coming from a science background we
actually have a near-perfect natural
experiment to look at the controlled for
these relevant variables Liz McGill at
Penn was another female president ivy
league university facing backlash for
identical remarks at the same
Congressional hearing but unlike gay
McGill was white and didn't have 50
charges of plagiarism against her right
and she received no support and resigned
almost immediately so I mean these these
claims are just so easily debunked it's
completely add OD with reality right and
that's the irony and I said that on Fox
a couple days ago to me it was like the
anti-Semitism thing I actually think
because she was a black woman she would
have got away with it it was only
because of 50 plus counts of plagurism
that finally they were like all right
this is this is a bit much but Andy you
you are well-versed in the radical left
and some of their tactics do you think
in a weird way they view her resigning
and by the way she's keeping her
$900,000 salary and will be part of the
political science department at Harvard
so it's not like she's getting smacked
down too hard do you think in a weird
way they they wanted this outcome
because in some ways it proves their
theory that the white woman the sorry
that the black woman in power will
always be taken out so it just adds more
fuel to
that no I don't think they actually
wanted this outcome I think up until now
um the elite woke who have control over
institutions have had just win after win
and um you know the takedown of um
claudian gay is symbolic in in the sense
that she's just one among many many
powerful figures who are part of this
apparatus of Dei CRT and woke ideology
however I do think um her resonation
disgraces is though the outcome is a
mixed bag in that it's not you know she
she retains a a tenured position at
Harvard and will continue to have
influence over her colleagues and
students um despite committing the worst
sin in academ which is plagiarism um but
I think those who have dedicated um uh
advocacy against Dei should really see
the significance of this as overall a
huge Victory because of the fact that
there was um some Buy in from the
mainstreem liberal left not entirely but
enough enough that we see it and we hear
it and that's actually really
significant
I think um the power of the woke left or
whatever you want to call it the farle
um is in the fact that they have been
able to have such a strangle hold and
control over mainstream uh liberal Elite
institutions and cultures and for there
now to be very small cracks to be
showing you can see how those who are
sort of uh have benefited from this have
been reacting they're reacting um
they're really freaking out which is why
they are treating this uh herination as
such a horrific thing to have happened
um because they're scared and we those
who want to see this entire system top
will really have to keep up to pressure
um the work that rufo and others like
him have done uh on Claude ying and
others has been so important and we
really have to support their journalism
and their activism
indeed indeed and you're actually giving
me a perfect segue there because when
you talk about those cracks breaking
through to the mainstream Coleman Hughes
who's an author he's also been on the
show and I think another guy that you
could probably consider on that sort of
Center left side a couple years ago who
let's say is shifted who happens to be
black well he was on CNN and they asked
him about what should have happened to
claudian gay so you don't think there
was anything um about this that had to
do with the fact that she was a black
woman from the from the people who were
claiming this as a victory against Dei
diversity equity and inclusion I don't
think it did and and you know what even
if it did that doesn't justify it if if
if you or I did this or even any white
scholar it would be career ending to
have 50 examples of plagiarism and it
has to be because how can you be the one
upholding Harvard's Integrity when you
yourself have failed it's it's as if the
commissioner of the Major League
Baseball or the NBA had a lifelong
history of steroid use and was now the
person in charge of kicking other people
out for steroid use it's completely
untenable what's your view on whether or
not this idea that uh the race of the
person accused is not important here so
I I think it's definitely uh a point
here that really um we have to look at
because you know the example you gave
for the Stan the president of Stanford
you know when he came on he had s months
of an investigation there was an
internal investigation Kirkland Ellis
was hired to actually go through and do
a thorough view of the analysis of all
his academic work to go back and find
that there was very serious allegations
of plagiarism Harvard Corporation did an
investigation they could have done
internal investigation it took several
months why is it that it took seven
weeks to decide that this was too much
whereas the president of Stanford got
seven months for the for similar
allegations I mean why do you think
obviously I should say I mean there was
obviously the anti-Semitism issue her
testimony before Congress which put her
in the hot water to begin with but but
after Harvard moved past that internally
this was the thing yes this was the
thing and and well my question about the
internal Harvard Review that you seem to
think was a very rigorous process is how
did they only find what four or five
examples of it when there were 50 almost
50 to find and plagiarism it's not like
uh it's it's not like True Crime where
there's there's a million perspectives
on it you kind of either lifted the
paragraph or you didn't it's just great
work right by Coleman like he's just
telling the truth it's interesting
because the other guest isn't saying
that
plagiarism uh is okay but he's basically
like oh well they just did this too
quickly like that's not legit in
academic circles is it
Colin not even a little bit I mean we're
seeing this sort of language game trying
to not even call it plagiarism call it
duplicative language um you know I've
seen a lot of activists come out and
saying oh you don't know what plagiarism
really is but her plagiarism of violated
Harvard's letter of what plagiarism
actually is uh overtly in about every
single way possible um so yeah I mean
Coleman is of course right on that if
you're at a place like you know Harvard
which is supposed to be the most
prestigious University in the world
having this this Mar on your record of
of uh you know academic uh type of
academic fraud is just completely
unacceptable there would be one thing if
she was ahe of a corporation or
something uh you know that selling
phones or something like that but no
this is an academic institution so you
need to have you know the utmost rigor
with uh with who's representing these
things you can't have the double
standard for the president uh versus the
students that are being you know
expelled for for much lesser infractions
Andy do you think this is going to light
a fire through the other academic
institutions not just the ivy league but
where we're going to find out that a
whole bunch of professors of presidents
of Faculty members all all sorts of
people have been lifting things stealing
not having the the proper qualifications
Etc well I don't think the institutions
themselves will have a fire under them
to do reviews of um their uh faculty
however I suppose a roffo fire let's say
yes well what I do have hope in and is
that more you know with the
investigations into ciding gay that were
done by uh Grassroots activists that is
the allog together thousands of hours
split among essentially crowdsourced
through the public a not not entirely
the public but a number of people
working um uh paragraph by paragraph
through her work now for that that level
analysis to be applied um to other
academics and other activ to other
so-called leaders um it's going to take
a lot of work and um I I I hope now that
this can continue because I think the
outrageous reactions we've seen from
some of the Dei ideologues may be
because some of them have
um in their own background in their own
work things that they would not want
people to uh
scrutinize um we're having a little
taste of that with ibx kend's um
research I mean there are former
colleagues of his at at his so-called
anti-racism Research Center um who have
now accused him of a really serious
misconduct um that Center has had
millions and millions of money poured
into research that they haven't produced
really anything and so this type of
scrutiny really has to be applied to not
just individuals but also institutions I
think the splc needs to be scrutinized
in that way um uh as well as other
so-called like uh hate watch
organizations that purport to protect uh
civil rights and by the way now that we
have ai it's going to be a hell of a lot
easier to be comparing and contrasting
old papers and new papers and doing some
of the research as opposed to manually
having you know grad students going
through all this stuff trying to figure
out if they were copy and paste jobs but
let's let's move over to the second
topic because I mentioned this is the
woke week that was and we got some wins
so it is a win one way or another that
claudian gay is no longer the president
of Harvard uh another was the
reaction uh by the fans to this new
director of the Star Wars film so uh yes
Star Wars has handed its 67 billion
Empire whatever is left of its Empire uh
to a a feminist take a look so the first
woman and the first person of color to
direct a Star Wars film it's set to be
released in 2026 you can say that the
force is strong with this one here's
charmino beino
you know I'm very thrilled about the
project because I think um what we are
about to create is something very
special and we're in 2024 now and I
think uh it's about time that we had a
woman uh come forward uh to shape the
story in a galaxy far far
away okay first off everyone's heard me
on this Kathleen Kennedy has been
running Star Wars for the last 10 years
she is a woman she has basically
completely destroyed it uh Colin I think
you're a big Star Wars guy as well uh I
suspect you are not thrilled that they
have handed this to a woman who thinks
that in and of itself being a woman is a
reason to direct Star
Wars I mean it's all the same stuff with
the identitarianism you know so they're
just injecting the activism directly
into the films and this is the problem
with a lot of the woke idogs they can't
just make movies that embody their
Vision they have to make the movie
overtly about the activism itself and
always ends up being cringe you know if
you want to challenge Norms just write
your strong female characters this has
been done in ways that doesn't Center
activism souria Weaver an alien Jennifer
Lawrence Hunger Games uh I even usually
bring up like things like Bridesmaids
which I thought it was a hilarious movie
with an all female cast because they
wrote Good characters and they were
funny but then you have another movie
female Ghostbusters which had almost the
exact same cast and it was terrible
because it was overtly shoving activism
down throats so the last thing that the
Star Wars needs is to continue down this
activist path just write the good
characters and the good stories so I
mean hopefully once they see the numbers
of the box office we'll change course
but it might take a few more for them to
really get the picture wouldn't that be
something making art for art sake by the
way I have a technical question maybe
one of you guys can help me out with I
bought years ago the the female
Ghostbusters on Apple TV because I
wanted to see it just so I could talk
about it on the show I knew it was going
to be horrible but I how do you delete
something that you bought on Apple TV I
don't know that it's possible I can't
all right I'm going to have my crack
team get on that um I want to show you a
video so this is from 8 years ago this
is this woman her name uh obiad shinoy
uh this is her talking about John
Stewart's interviewing her and you'll
recognize a couple other people on the
panel uh talking about what her
intentions are when she gets a film in
her hands what is the balance of
activating a force for
change but also trying to
permeate that patriarchy that power
structure and is that a part of the
calculation of your art as well and and
what's been the reaction to that oh
absolutely um I like to make men
uncomfortable I enjoy making men
uncomfortable not you just just not not
taken point
taken but um you know it is important to
be able to look into the eyes of a man
and say I am here and recognize that and
recognize that I am working to bring
something that makes you uncomfortable
and it should make you uncomfortable
because you need to change your attitude
and it's only when you're uncomfortable
when you're Shifty when you have to have
difficult conversations that you will
perhaps look at yourself in the mirror
and not like the reflection and then say
maybe there is something wrong with the
way I think or maybe there is something
wrong with the way I am addressing this
issue dy I remember when I was 5 years
old the first time I saw Star Wars and I
went into the bathroom after and I
stared in the mirror for like an hour
and I said you're a horrible person Dave
you're you're a boy here you're just
ter they're killing everything and by
the way John Stewart come yeah you got
to break the patriarchy like what a cuck
that's what they say a cuck
yeah so my my reaction after see seeing
some of these interviews of this um
female director I wasn't familiar with
with her before is um you know the the
arrogance that one has to have to feel
um that to be quite openly careless
about they're they're handed she's been
handed this Legacy of this film
franchise that has taken decades and
decades to build has millions of fans
around the world I mean personally I I
I'm not a Star Wars fan so I it doesn't
personally mean a lot to me but I know
through friends and throughout people my
in my life growing up how much it has
meant to them and you know well we
haven't seen the film that um you know
and we won't for a long time until it
comes out which she ultimately makes but
people should be concerned that somebody
who has this history of saying these
things of having a a political
philosophical agenda in her work is now
been handed this huge franchise with
this Legacy um I just think first off
that it's it's really hugely
disrespectful to the fans and I think um
it it I mean it it speaks to the the Le
the lack of leadership I think from
Disney and how they've handled huge um
uh you know their brand I mean we we saw
with how with the live action of Snow
White with their their lead for the um
Snow White actress saying all these
things essentially um crapping all over
the the the first Disney film that made
uh Disney that made Disney have the
Legacy it have today for her to dismiss
it in these interviews about um uh how
it was essentially a bad film and that's
no way it was a bad character it's uh
you know so we see the arrogance coming
from not just actors and films which is
unfortunately to be expected but also
from directors and by the way Disney
announced a few years ago when they got
both Star Wars and Marvel that they were
going to push Star Wars to be more for
young girls and the Marvel Universe to
be more for young boys so they that is a
type of social engineering isn't it
Colin yeah absolutely they this is all
part of like a a bigger pattern that you
see like happening in so many different
institutions where they take an
institution that has this Legacy this
history this earned prestige
and then the activists just at the 11th
Hour hop in the driver's seat Commander
the whole thing just to use as a
megaphone to spout their own ideologies
and you know undermine the entire Legacy
uh that's there we see this with the
ACLU we see we're seeing this with
Harvard how you know all this Prestige
they had now they're just you know
spouting racialist ideologies uh Star
Wars is doing this now we've seen
medical institutions do this this is
just part of the broader you know
activist Narrative of sort of taking
over the institutions uh and
commandeering them to their own ends and
uh yeah I think I mean this is a pattern
that we're seeing and it's it's going to
keep going and hopefully we can start
pushing back against this and I think
again at the box office this is where
ultimately it's going to uh it's going
to get the push back that it deserves
right the push back is the key part so I
mentioned this there were some wins so
it's a win for claudian gay to have
resigned I think there's a reaction win
in this Star Wars story there was nobody
out there like this is a great idea
everybody was pushing against it we'll
see ultimately what the movie will look
like I want to show another one that I
think we can frame as a win because
finally it seems to me that what's going
on at our border here is bubbling up
into the mainstream it's gotten so out
of control that mainstream is finally
starting to cover it uh check out what
this migrant Caravan this is the largest
migrant Caravan heading to the US right
now it's known as the poverty Exodus
about
15,000 people take a
[Music]
look
um Andy they're not criminals they're
International workers that might be true
I suspect that's not the case for
everybody but isn't it a moot point we
have a border and you can't just Rampage
through our border or I guess you
can what surprises me is that people are
are shocked and surprised when they see
these videos because this has been going
on um at a similar scale now um at the
US Southern border for years I mean
going back many many months there has
been an average of at some Peaks around
200,000 illegal border crossings through
the southern border happening per month
in December it was particularly
noteworthy because it was um the highest
record I think at
225 uh th000 documented illegal Crossing
things um I think because America is
such a huge country uh it's easy for
media and for for people the citizens to
also to turn a blind eye to the impact
of illegal migration um if you're in a
community in in one of the northern
states you're not going to be impacted
in the same way um whereas with migrant
crisis that happen let's say in Europe
you know when a whole country is the
size of one state and you have hundreds
of thousands of people coming in people
do see it and they react and politics
shift very rapidly because of that um in
the US things move bit more slowly I
think uh it's actually been really
important um in terms
of raising awareness that we've had
Governors now uh
allowing um these uh Asylum Seekers to
then go to a City destination of choice
such as Chicago and New York and now
some the impact that it's happening in
these other places is making it more of
a bigger issue for Democrats that's
important it's unfortunate that it has
to that they have to feel the impact of
mass legal migration for them to start
pushing back um but yeah if that if that
pressure is not spread evenly the
Democrats will continue to to I mean
what they would like is for it to to
continue to turn a blind eye and just
mislead the public about how serious
this problem is right so Colin I know
this one isn't a win yet because we're
watching this happen to our border right
now and certainly if you live in those
border cities or you live in the
sanctuary cities this is no good and
it'll it'll proliferate everywhere
actually but the the reason I view it as
a win is if we flash back to that stick
character who was a little bit on the
left a couple years ago this seems to be
an issue that is waking up people and is
shifting their voting
habits exactly as Andy mentioned you're
getting now Democrats that are starting
to talk about this because of that you
know concerted effort to make it
impacted uh to the the you know the the
blue States so they actually are feeling
the type of immigration that you know a
lot of the red States and border states
have been feeling for a while now you
know it's hard to believe this is even
like a controversial issue I remember 10
years ago I had hadn't really paid
attention to the Border issue I was
arguing with a friend about you know why
it's important to have borders uh they
told me there was no real crisis because
only something like a 100,000 people
came over a month and at the time I
didn't even know that that was the stat
and it just was completely shocking to
me my guess was probably it was on the
order of maybe 10,000 a month or
something and let me be clear 10,000
would also be a ridiculous number so I
mean I just think sometimes you just see
the numbers and they just don't mean
anything you just add another zeros like
what just I don't even know how to
comprehend this amount of people um so
you know the only way uh to get people
to actually do something is when it
shows up in their communi so I think I
think we're on a track to get a victory
here as well right and the reason at
least one of the reasons that the
numbers don't seem to miss uh mean
anything is because our leaders and
their spokespeople just give us complete
nonsense check out Karin jeanpierre
we're going to show her from this week
and then it's going to show what she was
saying two weeks ago um a couple weeks
ago you had said what we're seeing at
the border isn't unusual but in the
month of December there were more than
302,000 migrant encounters
uh the highest total for a single month
ever reported so does the administration
concede that what we're seeing now is
unusual what I said was to be exact is
that what we're seeing at the US is is
uh is es and flows and how many migrants
arrive up the Border it's something that
happens every year it es and flows and
what we're seeing here at the border the
migration flow uh increased migration
flow certainly uh it you know it es and
flows and we're at a time of the year
where we're seeing more uh at the the
border and it's not unusual this is an
immigration system that has been broken
for
decades I will give her some sort of
credit there in that she did say two
weeks ago that it es and flows but atie
she's treating immigration as if it's
weather like oh yes it's December and
it's a little bit colder and when we get
like this is just complete nonsense and
it's irrelevant we either have a border
or we
don't well it's no surprise that she
would downplay the seriousness of what's
been happening because immigration when
it's made as a an issue for voters uh
that doesn't de that does not benefit
Ben um benefit the Democrat Party
so I mean it's unfortunate that it's had
to take such an a long ongoing crisis
for for the administration to be asked
more and more uh my the longer questions
I have though is what can this or the
next Administration do I mean even you
know reminder even under the Trump trp
Administration a a completed border wall
was unable to take place and so this
this is an issue that seems going to be
with America because of our our our
politics uh potentially indefinitely I
don't know if there's a will really to
um to shut down the the pathways and
routes for Mass illegal migration to the
US you know it's not and people often
think about it's like as Colin said its
numbers 20,000 200,000 500,000 million
these numbers just become kind of
abstract when you see them as numbers
but the impact um on on housing on
resources the significant strain on
taxpayer funds that are needed to house
and to feed and to educate um all these
people who come in and of course there a
security issue as well when people are
coming in um usually with no documents
uh because they destroy their identity
papers so you don't even know who who
they even are so it's uh um
unfortunately this is uh it seems like a
problem
that there's no will in either really
party or way um to to stall Andy you
gave me another great segue to the final
uh segment today because you've been
covering these antifa protests for years
and now as you mentioned you're in the
UK now in London and you've been
covering a lot of uh these pramas
rallies which of course are not only in
London but all over Europe and in the
United States and in Canada and
elsewhere uh tomorrow on January 6th
there is supposedly going to be a
massive uh and this was advertised by
BLM so you can see how these things are
really connected BLM and Hamas and the
rest of it uh a massive rally in the UK
I want to just show you the ad that
they're putting out for this
[Music]
thing
Andy let me jump back to you first on
this because uh when I was in London
when I saw you at the r conference uh I
drove by one of those rallies and it was
very obvious to me that it would not
have been safe if I was outside we have
you know and recognized certainly um
it's very obvious that the Jewish
community in London does not feel safe
there are pro Hamas posters River to the
Sea all of the slogans etc etc uh you've
been covering this from America from
Portland with antifa to now can you just
talk about this Confluence of of strange
um issues that are all coming together
so the makeup of the uh I'll just call
them Pro Palestine demonstrations have
happened in the UK the political makeup
is pretty similar to the US uh all over
in the west actually you see this
strange bad fellows Coalition of
Palestinian nationalists um Arab Nation
nationalists um Muslim radicals
islamists jihadist
sympathizers uh liberals and the radical
left uh some of these groups have
nothing in common in fact uh are quite
against one another but together uh they
are protesting for this particular cause
uh in the UK since the 7th of October as
in many many countries around the world
we've seen these huge demonstrations
that have um at times led to instances
of violence uh extremism
anti-Semitism uh and property
destruction I think
um in in the UK there there are
restrictions on for example um inviting
support for a banned terrorist group
Hamas is one of those groups so the
language is slightly it can be a bit
more subtle in the UK because there have
been a number there have been dozens of
people who have been arrested at some of
these rallies due to signs and
statements they've made that are um
perceived by law enforcement to be
violent extremists um we don't have
those limitations in the US and you can
kind of see in my view more of the true
face of what um the mainstream Pro
Palestine demonstrations are by looking
at what happens in America you see those
who bring over and over Hamas Flags um
pictures of Hamas leadership um the
chance are much more explicit in their
calls for violence it's a bit more toned
down in in Europe in some most instances
although not always ways um because
there are more Muslims um in the UK and
in Western Europe than there are in
America you see much more of a attempt
by uh islamists to explicitly make this
into a religious conflict where it it is
now the religious duty of Muslims to
show solidarity for Palestine by any
means necessary and there have been
already a number of Terror attacks um
that have happened in the UK and Western
Europe since the 7th of October that law
law enforcement say were inspired by the
current conflict involving Israel and
Hamas right and then you look back to
the previous segment we just did and we
are allowing hundreds of thousands of
people into our borders having no idea
what they believe or where their
allegiances are or anything else but you
bring up an interesting point about
speech and what is allowed and what is
not I think the main thing that we're
struggling with here it's one thing if
you're going to chant River to the Sea
and whatever and what are the limits of
of the First Amendment are the other
thing is though they are blocking
Bridges they are stopping traffic
stopping people from getting to airports
here's video uh on New Year's Day
protesters uh at the Rose Parade in
[Music]
[Applause]
Pasadena
team
[Music]
[Applause]
Colin I'm fairly certain that if Israel
was losing they would not be calling for
a ceasefire they'd be pretty thrilled
but that aside how long do you think a
society can hold when on any given day
any group with whatever their grievances
can shut down a bridge shut down an
airport shut down a parade uh stop
people from going into a mall etc etc
that to me seems like the issue that
we're they're sort of testing what
western societies are willing to
tolerate and I think we're failing the
test exactly I mean it it's it's
mind-boggling how we don't just enforce
the the law as written and remove people
from streets who are blocking you know
the flow of traffic um you know I'm
going to actually going to count this as
another win you know we've been trying
to tally some wins going on here it
might seem like hard to find a win out
of all of this but there is a silver
lining in this because I think with
regard to the whole Palestine and Hamas
and all this stuff the woke left's mask
has completely fallen off here their
aggressive ideology is fully exposed we
see the woke identitarian ideologies
like CRT and decolonization we see where
these things lead where they sort of
have this simplified oppressor oppressed
you know being a DEC colonizer uh
apparently means you can justify
anything against colonizers including
rape and murder it's it's woken up so
many liberals moderate liberals from the
dangers of wokeness and I believe we've
reached a Tipping Point here we've
waited for a sort of mass Awakening to
push back against the threat of the
great awokening like we've had gay
ousted more universities are ejecting
Dei corporations are to we need need to
ensure that this momentum doesn't lead
up you know Dei capitalized on the
momentum from George Floyd's death uh
pushed the radical ideology far and wide
now it's our turn to sort of March it
back to where it was you know not only
where it was but you know back out of
America for good I think so I think this
is a win um and we're going to see uh
some improvements from here at least I
hope Colin I always try to end the show
on a positive note you gave me the win
on that one so I thank you you're
welcome back anytime Andy as always
you're welcome back have a great weekend
guys and for everybody else we have a
postgame show coming up in about 30
seconds at Ruben report. locals.com
thanks for watching
[Music]
everybody